.
I'm going to gavel this committee of conference into order.
This is on a committee of conference on house bill 1299.
There's been an amendment submitted to all members.
I had a conversation with Senator Avard.
This amendment just puts the process in alignment with all the other appeals processes that happen at Fish and Game where the decision is made by the chief.
And then if the decision of the chief wants to be appealed, that appeal goes to the executive director.
This amendment puts this process in alignment with all those other processes.
And I understand from Senator Avard, the Senate will agree to the amendment and will accede to the Senate position with the minor changes.
Is that correct?
Mr.
Chairman, that is correct.
speaking for Senator Avard and the Senate members.
We accept that amendment that makes the director the appeal person and the Senate members.
We accept that amendment that makes the director, the appeal person, and the chief of wildlife, the applicant's first step.
And so I've reviewed the amendment as has Senator Rayvard.
We are in concurrence with that amendment, and we are grateful for your accession to the Senate position.
Thank you very much.
And with that, the meeting is closed.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
We will now call the order of the Committee of Conference on House Bill 1476.
So, anything change from yesterday?
Yeah, Senator Seuss has said it's raining.
um no i think the focus should be on violent offenders.
And we hope that, you know, you folks would proceed to the Senate position.
And, you know, with a week for the advocates to work this, I think you have a shot at it.
And that's all we can ask.
I think, as I think, you know, in listening to what you folks were saying yesterday, you think the focus should be on violent criminals, but you're concerned about not being able to get it across the finish line.
And I just would remind you that when it went to the floor, it wasn't your language.
It was the language in 294.
So your language is different, better, quite frankly.
And when 294 went to the floor was without recommendation, This would be a affirmative vote of the committee of conference.
The advocates would work incredibly hard.
They promised me that.
Give it a shot.
Representative Rhodes.
Thank you, Mr.
Chairman.
So I think I'm a little bit confused because my understanding of a committee of conferences to come both sit down at the table.
And it appears to me that if your position is already made, it kind of puts us in a hard spot to start out.
But with that being said, we heard from law enforcement.
And when we actually had the opportunities to hear from the victims, which sadly isn't often because usually they're intimidating to submission, is that these most egregious crimes are often repeated.
It is repeated behavior.
We hear that all the time.
They're all sitting here.
They're all telling you that all over again.
So I'm just confused on why this is so confusing.
And I think that I would like to know what it is about the House's position that is so egregious to the Senate that you hold repeat offenders to a higher standard.
As I tried to explain yesterday, the original version of my bill, Senate Bill 294, had a provision similar to Ross's in that bill.
It was at the suggestion of Representative Abbas, I removed that.
Happy to put that back in.
But I think if you bring some of the law enforcement folks that are here and put them there and ask them the question as to what's the most important, they're going to tell you it's the Senate version of the bill.
And that's why we're here to stress violent criminals.
I want to do something about repeat offenders.
Don't get me wrong, but not at the expense of dropping violent criminal.
Just to make sure we're all talking about the same sections of what was 294.
There was one section that had to do with if you have been charged with a drunk driving, class A misdemeanor, or a felony while out on bail already.
And now you get a third time that happens.
You now have three open cases while out on bail.
At that, there was one section that would apply where a person would then be held, the presumption that they'll be held.
And the reason why is they won't comply with the conditions of their release.
So they're now in pretrial detention.
That's one section.
What 1476 addresses is simply a person's out on bail or they're awaiting a sentence.
They get arrested, which is a violation of their bail.
But this is not necessarily related to the pretrial detention.
This is what you do between the time the person's been arrested and whether they're brought before court and this says a time where they'll be held they basically will be held and brought before a judge to decide whether they should be released that's what 1476 does so the repeat offenders side of it we're not necessarily this is not the house position will not necessarily result in someone being held in pre-child detention.
They're just not going to get released that same day, at least in all likelihood they won't.
And that's somewhat similar to the Senate position, which is, I helped draft, but that has to do with someone who's not necessarily out on bail.
They're being brought before a judge as opposed to a bail commissioner because of the nature of the offense.
So I guess the question I have is if the House position, if we could pass the House position, why can't we pass the Senate position?
They can be together.
I'm just wondering why can't they coexist because they don't conflict.
We would need to take a recess to think about that.
If they don't conflict, we'd be in favor of that, I think.
I'd want to, you know, poll the other senators.
But if technically they hold together, and I think we'd want to, you know, talk to our law enforcement friends and maybe put them right up here and ask them, we want to deal with repeat offenders.
But again, and I'm sorry to keep sounding like a broken record, but it was your suggestion that we took out the repeat offender provision so that it would give you a better opportunity to get it passed.
So I will tell you this.
The motion to table, which I opposed, I did the PI to opposing that, it wasn't even close.
When I say it wasn't close, was it 85 votes we were short?
No, you were short hundreds.
Hundreds.
If I may, Mr.
Chairman.
Senator Barry.
Senator Bradley keeps saying you, you, you, you.
He's referencing you, Mr.
Chairman.
He's not referencing the House.
The House sent over its reform.
It was 1476.
I would be amenable to the idea of combining the two because, as I said, the way we would have to combine them would have to be some form in which the House position is the base.
And the reason is, is I have to go back to the House and get the votes.
And if it is interpreted as being based off of the Senate position, it is dead.
It's just done so.
If it is crafted off of the House position, it is an easier sell for me to go get the votes that we need to get it passed.
The members of law enforcement were in favor of HB 1476 when the House passed it.
I don't know what happened when it came over to the Senate.
They indicated they're in favor of what you passed, maybe we can have our cake and eat it too if you guys want to recess i think that would i'm not the chairman but i definitely would uh i definitely would think that would be appropriate i just want to ask one question if i may before we return if so looking at the house version i'm on line seven and eight If the issue is repeat offense and subsequent offense, then why does it include Class B misdemeanors and say shall be?
So it's three arrests for Class B misdemeanors.
There are some serious Class B misdemeanors such as DWI.
These aren't just like jaywalking.
There are some serious Class B misdemeanors.
I know what class B misdemeanors are, but there's a comma after class B misdemeanor.
So that's one thing.
And then third or subsequent offense is separate.
So the way this is currently drafted, it's one class B misdemeanor, and then it's subsequent other offenses.
Either you have to take out the comma or you have to rearrange this sentence if you're solely looking at repeat offenders.
So I interpret the same way, and if you can tell by maybe my facial expression, I am surprised how one can pass the house very easily and another can't even make it out of the committee, never mind to the floor for a discussion.
But at the same time, that's what we're dealing with.
So the logic of how this is playing out, I've given up on that.
Wait a minute, Mr.
Chairman.
I agree.
Take the calm out.
Make it the same.
We're not going to let who goes first, calm us, but we're coming out of here with something today.
So let's get this fixed.
Take whatever.
Take the comm out.
And let's do this.
Combine them.
Can we have a couple of minute recess?
We can take a break.
Okay.
I have a 1.30 conference with you, unless you've been replaced.
I'll follow you.
Thank you.
Good afternoon again.
We'll now call the order of the Committee of Conference again on HB 1476.
So we'd like to offer a compromise marrying the two versions, the House and Senate version.
So the Senate version would remain intact as it is presented.
And we would suggest amending the House version, starting on line seven, delete the word may.
So it reads, or a person charged with a class B misdemeanor, remove that comma, third or subsequent offense, may replace shall with may be detained for a period of not more than 36 hours from the time of arrest excluding Saturday Sundays and holidays then we would remove starting on line 17 and notwithstanding paragraph three shall be held in preventive detention right well we would take that part out though we would We would say you are detained without bail, pending a hearing before a judge, period.
And then the effective date would have to be January 1st to effectuate the Senate changes.
If we could, if you would indulge Mr.
Head from the judicial branch, he had a couple of other that he thought possibly we may need to do.
Go ahead.
One at a time.
So one inconsistency, and this is more technical, under the Senate position, it's 24 to 36 hours, and it kind of explains when the 36 hours would apply as opposed to 24.
That was mirrored.
When I put that together, that was mirrored after Superior Court Rule 10 and Circuit Court Rule 4.
And I know I did discuss that language with the Attorney General's office.
So that begins on page 2 of the Senate version, line 4.
Is that what you're referencing, Mr.
Chairman?
Yes.
Okay.
It's lines four and five.
I would suggest that we keep the 24 to 36 language from the Senate version and merge that into the House draft.
So the House just says 36.
Now we'll keep the consistency with the court rules.
May I ask a question?
Representative Barrett.
I just want to go over the maize and shalls because that was brought up in the House hearing on 1476.
What is the intention there?
I'm not opposed to it.
I just want to know what the intention is.
To give the court discretion.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Because when I wrote it, the point was not that they shall be held for 36 hours, that they shall be held until they see a judge.
That was the point of that language, not they shall be held for 36 hours.
They shall be held for 36 hours or until they see a judge, whichever was first.
That's what we intended to pass.
So I just want to make sure by May we're not just letting people off.
Well, I think what we're trying to do is give the judges greater discretion.
So it's pending.
I think the key here is that we retain the language in 18 and 19 that say without bill pending a hearing before a judge.
The key is...
So long as it doesn't say after 36.
So if the judge lets them off, that's fine fine but we're still going to hold them for up to 36 hours until they get to the judge that that stays in place that's your understanding okay so so basically we're just because that was the house's position so we're just this is grammatical that's kind of what i'm getting at okay i think by getting and i think we might want to hear from as you perhaps attorney head, and then there are also representatives from law enforcement here that may want to weigh in.
I believe by changing it to May, it's not requiring the person be detained improper before a judge.
They would still be permitted to go before a bail commissioner.
I think the idea, at least I understand the intent of 1476 and the House and Senate positions really to not have this hearing before bail commissioners, to have it before a judge.
So by changing shall to may, I think it's kind of stripping.
So you're removing that middle language and you say may may be held without bail, pending a hearing before the judge.
A period of not more than 36 hours from the time of their arrest, excluding Sunday's holidays, and we incorporate the other language without bail, pending a hearing before a judge.
They may be held pending a hearing.
So let's just play this out.
So class B misdemeanor, and as I said, we could have others confirm, but it could be a series of petty thefts.
I see what you're saying.
There has to be a degree of discretion where we're not tying up the holding stuff for people that stole a banana on one day an apple the next and then once they hit the orange i think i understand what you're saying basically maybe i'm not but you don't want them arrested for something they wouldn't have otherwise been arrested for you mean held held held yeah well because yeah because they could be arrested arrested and released immediately they want them taken to the holding.
Okay, because that's our intention.
Okay, so if that's how it is, then I'm fine with that.
Because I share the – if that is your concern, I share that concern.
Someone who's arrested for picking up a banana should not be.
But if it's a defense that involves you going to jail, once you are in jail, you're underneath this system of you're going before a judge if you're on your second or if it's these crimes, you're the first one.
Correct?
We're all in agreement on that?
Mr.
Chair.
If I can just comment, Senator Bradley, that would – the Class B misdemeanors are something that you don't have – you don't go to jail for.
So it would need to be a Class A misdemeanor or a felony.
That's how it would have to read.
You can't keep class B misdemeanor in there in that case.
Now, the confusion link, we included drunk driving in prior versions.
The reason why was the public safety concern, particularly with that type of crime.
But here, I would just change that to class A misdemeanor or felony, as opposed to saying class B.
If they're comfortable with May, there's no reason to change it even more.
If they're comfortable with May and that's the intention, let's just leave it at that and move on.
Is that fine with you guys?
I think for, you know, and certainly other members of our committee can chime in, but I think the key portion for us is that there are certain severe penalty, felony crimes, which are delineated here in the Senate version that we believe require a hearing before a judge.
Yeah, we agree with that wholeheartedly.
um and that's retained and then we can wordsmith this further and as i said if we hear from others if they're a concern happy to Yeah, we agree with that wholeheartedly.
If that's retained, and then we can wordsmith this further.
And as I said, if we hear from others, if they're a concern, happy to keep wordsmithing this.
But I think we can try to marry up the two.
This is more a process request.
What if Representative Barry and Representative Roy Rhodes, Gannon, and Susie work on crafting an amendment that we could come back here at 2.30, and we could hear from law enforcement.
I know it's getting tight on the deadline, but you and I have a committee of conference across the city, and then I have the parking garage at 2.
I'm actually chairing that for the House.
I have some good news, Senator Bradley.
I figured this is where we were going to end up, and I submitted this amendment at noon today.
So OLS is already ahead of the game.
With the maze and the commas?
We have to do the maze and the commas, but the Senate's position of violent crimes and the House-based bill, OLS is currently working on it.
I know my Senate colleagues are very reasonable, and I figured this is where we're going to end up.
And I knew you had a tight deadline, so I wanted to go ahead and take care of it.
And if anybody wants to co-sponsor it with me, they're more than happy to.
I think we should refer to it as the Barry Amendment.
I'm good with that.
I just want to get across the street to the next one, given our deadlines.
That's all.
So we've got to do a quick vote.
Let's take a vote.
Aye.
You're all good?
A resounding yes.
Aye.
Are we going to see the language first?
I think we should come back at like 2.15 to 2.30.
See the language.
We should be okay.
Let's take a break till give or take around 2.15.
2.15.
I can't say that.
Let's take a break to 2.15.
But is that enough time to have everything signed off by 3?
Yes.
You need to tell me.
It should be given that I probably just got the draft in my pocket.
Could you guys please confer with Attorney Head, Bill?
We will take a break.
We'd be able to mark it up if we had a copy of the draft.
The 2.15.
Stay here.
Yeah.
This is the only one I have left.
Ross, can you share a copy of the draft?
Of course.
I don't know if I have it yet.
Okay.
Can you get OLS?
Actually, they just sent a new one.
Well, here we go.
I will forward it to everyone.
I haven't even read it again.
Okay.
Thank you.
now reconvene the committee conference on house bill 1476 is there a draft is there a draft we have here my understanding is in the house position it was a at the very end there was a provision about not permitting pr bail when someone has been released on bail and violated condition of their release.
For the third time.
And that's the only thing we're now held up on.
When did that change?
From the House position?
That's always been in there.
No, when we sat here and we agreed, we went to a different community conference conference now we came back and then it's changed like i don't understand how to change people are allowed to change your mind problem with the pr bail has been with the bail commission that was never discussed here that We've never discussed at this table.
Let's not talk over each other.
It wasn't.
The RBL wasn't.
It's not.
We're not going to talk over each other in here, right?
It reminds me of the committee when it's just the House members.
One at a time.
The PR bail plank of the House's reform is a key aspect of it.
We have conceded two positions already, 36 to 24, made a shall.
It's time that the Senate acquiesced to something that the House wants.
It's just – it is a – I am telling you, it is just something that we have to have.
It would seem to me that the House position has been opposed consistently to the reforms that the Senate is suggesting on violent crime.
And now you are digging in on basically ending PR bail.
I don't get where you're coming from with these potential small violations.
Yes, they accumulate.
But, you know, as Senator Seuss said before, the banana, the orange, the apple, three separate violations, and there's no flexibility.
The Senate position has been to go before a judge, and by striking this sentence, that's what it does.
And I think, Representative Perry, when you explain that to the House, they'll get it.
You have to explain it, as Senator Soucy has explained it, you know, through this afternoon committee conference.
Respectfully, if explaining it was that easy, we wouldn't be in a committee conference.
Senator Bradley, my issue is I represent South Willow Street, one of the largest retail strips in the state.
So we're talking about stealing from stores that I represent.
So I understand that I have to go back to the house, but I also have to go back to the people that elect me.
And I actually think I might represent the most retail spots in the state.
I heard Amherst Street in Nashville might have more.
It's nice to put up the, oh, it's a banana, it's a banana, it's a banana, but it's not a banana.
And somebody owns that store, a small business owner owns that store, and they're out.
And I'm a small business owner, by the way.
So we're not talking, it's not victimless crimes.
Theft is theft, and we can try to marginalize it as much as we want.
These crimes escalate.
And at the end of the day, I go back to we've acquiesced already.
We're telling you we have 15 minutes.
I'm not budging.
I can't speak for the other two representatives.
I just spoke with them and they told me they're not budging.
So unless we've moved, this is it.
And we can let this die right now.
And it is what it is.
But I feel like we have a package that the house is is it's already going to be hard for me to sell one and done to the house they've agreed to no pr for for third arrest on class b misdemeanors and i'll say it again there are serious crimes that are classified as class b misdemeanors including driving while intoxicated so it just is what it is and understand we just this this was last maybe one or two ago.
It was an issue out of Raymond, New Hampshire.
There was someone who had five drunk driving arrests in a two-month time period.
So that is something that we're dealing with.
And the issue is how does that happen?
They're getting bail and going out again, getting bail, getting released, arrested again in a two-month time period.
I'm not sure about the convictions on all those.
This is not abolishing PR bail.
You can still get PR bail, but if you are out and released on PR bail and you violate the conditions of your release the third time, and I understand that the fruit analogy that, but if you keep getting arrested and violate, what's the concept?
What is the consequence of that?
If of that?
Why have conditions of your release in the first place?
Why have you been arrested?
Well, I'm just saying if you violate the conditions and you set these, one of them is don't get arrested for any more crimes.
You keep getting arrested for more crimes.
Yes, they're not offenses you may go to jail for.
and it's not this provision, even if I don't feel strongly about it, I'm trying to get this to the floor for a debate in the House.
I have not been able to do it.
I'm praying that you guys allow me to do it today or do it next week because that's really what I want to do.
Can we take a two-minute break?
If I could before we take a break.
My sticking point is it's the third time.
This shows such an utter disrespect for the law in law enforcement.
I mean, one time, okay.
The third time while you're on bail, that's all we're asking for.
PR bail stays.
But if you get arrested three times, it shows no respect for the system of justice.
We have 13 minutes to get this done, so please let them take their two-minute break.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
We now reconvene the committee of conference on House Bill 1476.
My understanding is May will be returned back to Shell, but we would strike the PR language.
And if you commit the three offenses, you will be brought before a judge similar draft as the Senate position on the violent crimes section.
We all in agreement with that?
Yes.
I don't even have a copy of this.
That's almost a time crunch.
I know there was two shells in there.
I mean, two Mays.
We have the Senate attorney also answer some questions, Mr.
Chair.
Thank you.
We have the Senate attorney also answer some questions, Mr.
Chair.
You might want to give him that copy.
It is 255.
I can talk fast.
I think the question is whether or not it's permissible to have a statute that precludes an indigent person from being bailed when a person who has access to funds can be bailed.
And I think that the answer to that question is that you can't do it in a categorical way like that.
You have to maintain an opportunity for an indigent person to receive bail.
My understanding of what you're all saying doesn't do that.
It just effectively denies a third-time offender access to a bail commissioner just whether that person is indigent or whether that person has money and says that the only person who's going to bail that person is going to be a judge.
That's correct.
And how do we write that to reflect that?
Because I see everybody shaking or nodding their hand it's already written the senate position when i helped right that's what that provision as written it what it would do you just want to put that the policy of what is the house position but you take the procedures the procedural side merge it in and that's it.
But how does, is the language in the amendment that, and Rick has my copy of it, does it do that?
Lines 21 and 22.
And what I'm looking at say, the court shall not order personal recognizance bail in such cases.
Is it the intent to strike that?
Yes.
Do we need to add that language?
No.
No, we just have to change May to shall and strike out the line about PR bail.
May to shall in line 9?
And I believe it's 17.
I'm going off the top of my head.
It's not 17.
There's two of them.
No, that was the notwithstanding paragraph 3 section.
That's long gone.
Yeah, that's not in here.
We're just talking about number 9, line 9.
258, everyone.
All right.
That's it.
That's 258.
Made a shell.
Strike 21 and 22, the back half.
Good job.
401.
Yes.
I appreciate it.
Bill, did they talk to hear about 1431.
Yes, I'm going to send it.
Yes.
It's Bill, number one.
it is 1476 it's 259 so i'm i you know i'm not the official timekeeper well you don't have to worry about because your deadline's four ours is three i'm worried about senator morris is sitting right here If the Senate is not worried about its own deadlines, then we're all set.
I won't tell if you don't.
*** We're just checking.
It should be good, Darrell.
I want to make sure that everybody needs to be.
Yes, you did.
You got to pass it, though.
Yeah, I know you did.
Isn't there a rail trail?
Thank you.
Back from our break, reopening the committee conference on 1476.
It's going to be, Representative Berry is going to file the amendment.
I will accompany with him to make sure it's a report.
Thank you.
It's going to be written very similar to the procedure on the Senate position.
So it's going to say if you...
I don't have a draft.
I'm literally operating off of no draft.
So...
operating off of no draft.
So.
Going off of memory here, but in what was one time Senate bill 294, if you would scroll down after the violent crime section, there was another section if you kept defaulting in hearings, and there was another section if you kept getting arrested out on bail.
That's a different section, but the language in there had to do with committing certain offenses.
That's how you would want to write that.
Then you want to take the procedural side of this.
If you commit any of these offenses, after the third time, a person will be detained pending a bail hearing before a judge for 24 or 36 hours, depending on that language.
That's how it would flow.
Thank you.
And, of course, strike the PR bill restriction.
So, if you look at page two, I'm going to go.
So if you look at page 2, line 1, where it says, shall not be brought before a bail commissioner, and shall upon arrest be detained pending an arraignment before the court.
You've got to take that language and implement that into...
You see where it says on page one, line nine, where it's shall.
So you got to take that language and put it in there.
So it's saying the same thing.
Because when you say detained, that can mean a lot of things.
and I think that's part of the misinterpretation people have.
Detained waiting trial, detained waiting what...
It's detained pending your arraignment.
I just want that one.
Thank you.
If I may, Mr.
Chair, just one other thing just to make more clear.
line nine line nine, the issue that I had with the comma, we had changed that to, you go to line eight or an insert third or subsequent offense for a person charged with a class B misdemeanor.
I think makes it clearer no i want to move third or subsequent defense before a person charged with a class b misdemeanor So it's or third or subsequent offense for a person charged with a class B misdemeanor.
So it's or third or subsequent offense for a person charged with a class B misdemeanor.
Because otherwise, tell me why it's not just class B misdemeanor and then third or subsequent offense the way it's drafted.
I think you can take out the class B misdemeanor altogether and just say third or subsequent offense Because now you're including all offenses.
Am I correct?
Okay, then I'm going to maybe step back if we're doing that.
This is...
That's not a change.
No, class B misdemeanor was the position of the house.
That was your focus was Class B misdemeanors.
No.
If it just says third and subsequent offenses, it would cover a Class A misdemeanor, Class B misdemeanor.
No, I understand that.
And all felonies.
But why would you walk away?
Because you want to keep the Class B misdemeanors in there.
That's just walking away to walk away, if you ask me.
It's not changing the substance of how this is being applied.
Well, it is changing it because right now it's limited to class B misdemeanors.
Can we hear it from us?
Of course.
If you just have it be an offense, it includes violations.
And I think that's what Senator Soucy's's concern is she doesn't want it to go down to violation level you could have just be misdemeanor and then it would apply to aid misdemeanors be misdemeanors whatever um but i don't think the i don't think the intent was to have this apply to every three violations.
Violations of parking tickets.
You can't use the word 10.
All right, I understand.
So if you could do or, third or subsequent offense for a person charged with a Class B misdemeanor.
That keeps the language that was in the house first.
It just moves one phrase ahead of the other, so it modifies it.
You can see the misdemeanor.
That keeps the language that was in the House version.
It just moves one phrase ahead of the other, so it modifies it.
You could do it that way, or you could do it a person charged with a Class B misdemeanor having three times previously been charged with a misdemeanor or felony.
Because there's no, you mentioned this in an earlier bill, there's no subsequent offenses for most of these things.
That's not a crime.
It's, you're talking about somebody's record.
You're not talking about like DWI second offenses, its own offense.
I understood.
which are we going to do what Mr.
Lehman just suggested which is clear i think yes can we um somebody write i'll talk yeah we'll we'll write and you talk a person charged with a misdemeanor Class B misdemeanor who has three times previously been charged, arrested or charged?
Do you want it to apply to arrest or do you want it to apply to direct summonses?
Three times previously been charged with a misdemeanor.
Wait a minute.
A person charged with a class B misdemeanor.
Who has three times previously been charged with a misdemeanor or felony.
Shall be detained for a period of not more than 24 hours after the arrest and then as it's written there after the arrest, and then as it's written there.
It's the charges.
Yes, but that would go, I believe that what the attorney said captured that.
I don't think it was word for word, but he was kind of explaining it.
Can I read this?
Yes.
Okay, so on line 8, we're going to substitute in for the language on line 8 after the struck through May, or a person charged with a Class B misdemeanor who has three times previously been charged with a misdemeanor or felony shall be detained for a period of not more than 24 hours after the arrest.
Saturday, Sundays, legal holidays.
Right.
I didn't read that, but I'm assuming.
And then we would strike.
The court shall not order PR bail on such cases on line 21 and 22.
Is that correct?
I have two.
I apologize, Senator.
I have two people talking to me.
My understanding is that it would technically be a fourth arrest.
So I think what you're saying, you believe that this is now your third arrest, so it should be two prior.
Two prior.
We can't go to fourth arrest come on well it's in the matter of but you've had third or subsequent we're trying to mirror the language of the house position yeah i think he has to the language of this I believe the way it should be written is a person charged with a class B misdemeanor who has two times previously been charged with a misdemeanor or felony.
That makes it your third.
Yes.
If anybody wants to stand for the fourth of us, John helps.
Two times previously been charged.
The misdemeanor performance shall be detained for a few weeks.
Deleting the sentence on 21 and 22.
And there are no other changes.
I believe that satisfies what the House is willing to agree to.
Are we okay?
We'll be fine.
Okay.
Senate's okay.
Everyone okay here?
Yep.
I believe the way it works is you have to file the report.
And I'll come with you.
I'll bring Mr.
Lehman with us.
We can all walk over there together.
We can even link arms.
All right, well, this is awesome.
Thank you guys very much.
Thank you.
I'm glad we got this word out.
Many thanks to Senator Morris for stopping the clock for a few minutes.
Thank you, Chuck.
I heard he could stop time.
I didn't believe it.
He did it.
Morris for stopping the clock for a few minutes.
Thank you.